the honeymoon phase clearly over ladies
and gentlemen at the white house as we
have been discussing today the president
once again ignoring reporters the third
time in a week in the midst of multiple
bruising crises his poll numbers as you
know keep going south headline after
headlines showing how bad things are for
the commander-in-chief at least the
image now president biden facing a new
wave of criticism from the one place you
would not expect his friends in the
liberal mainstream media
right now um you know the honeymoon's
over we're so glad to see you joe biden
that's kind of how this year started the
problem is that he
put himself in a position where he made
big bold claims about the rest of the
agenda and then he steps on a rake and
then he slips on a banana peel and he
falls down the stairs with some marbles
and now people are looking at him in a
negative light
and you know kd that's uh ben jones
that's not uh tucker carlson and uh if
ben jones is saying honey they look
exactly the same must be true yeah well
he said that joe biden fell down the
stairs he literally fell up the stairs
then maybe that was an indication of how
things were going to go but in terms of
his agenda he's looking at being a lame
duck president very early on he's having
a very hard time getting his build back
better agenda passed bernie sanders came
out today saying they're not budging
christian cinema and joe manchin saying
we're not budging either so for someone
who promised to unite the country you
can't even unite democrats around his
agenda but the real question for people
like van jones is what did you expect i
mean joe biden is a guy who really
didn't do much when he was in the senate
in terms of getting really big pieces of
legislation passed he did a few things
here and there that then the left turned
on him for like the 1994 crime bill and
people warned about this and they said
that he was a guy who could bring
everyone together because he had 40
years of washington experience but he's
proving that he actually is a bureaucrat
of the system and he really can't get
things done that he promised on the
campaign trail in that regard dana
he needed with
it's not like he was fdr with the great
two-thirds of the senate and two-thirds
of the house representatives he has the
narrowest margin maybe in history he
needed popularity to get anything done
he got through those first emergency
measures but everything else is now
bogging down isn't it a fact that he
basically is a lame duck in in a sense
well from the beginning what they should
have been doing is setting expectations
for people saying especially the
progressives like i know that you would
like to do all of these things it is not
going to be possible so let's do what is
feasible let's try to get this done in
advance so we could try to grow our
majority that would have been the smart
thing instead they're talking about 3.5
trillion and even the giveaways people
aren't even into that and then the other
two things that are happening is that
they're not we're not arguing about
universal
child care or free community college
people are focused on the fact they
can't get out of the grocery store for
less than a hundred dollars and they're
being told that their home heating bills
are going to go up 53 over last year and
that their kids aren't going to get the
christmas presents that they want this
year the other thing is
they don't
he doesn't take questions
reporters of all stripes they have two
sacred cows access and process they give
them neither and so at this point what
are we left arguing over tweets and the
deeper the hole gets the harder it is
for him to get out of it
don't you think though a lot of it is
just image greg
my point is here's the guy he's fumbling
around the stock market went up over 500
points today a couple of big days like
that and this will be last week's story
i'm not so sure because you know it's
like entropy all the things starts
falling apart it's hard to get that
stuff back in this honeymoon was over
faster than ilhan omar and her brother
all right
it's the snottiest that's pretty funny
yes it is but it might this this this
this it might just be on pause because
the moment that they can re-christen joe
as the comeback kid on geritol they will
but i don't know if it really matters
because he's it doesn't matter to him
because he served his purpose right he
won
it's a good price this problem is a good
problem for the democrats they're
they've got to figure out now what do
they do and he's like what else do i
have to do for you i won you guys run
the country i'm going to go swim naked
in the pool so i don't know what a
visual yeah well people have seen it
secret service agents
have it i i still believe that
afghanistan poisoned everything
and
it
once the air of invulnerability was
pierced once the veil was pierced now
everyone's going to be it's going to be
death by a thousand blows rather than
cuts and to dana's point you remember
barack obama came out with the one big
thing it was obamacare and that was able
to unite all of the democrats around one
single thing joe biden took 16 different
things from these liberal wish lists and
just shoved it all into one spending
bill that costs trillions of dollars so
no one even knows what we're fighting
for he was supposed to unify us over
unity but remember that but right and
then all and also the real reason
geraldo and i know you agree with this
is because democrats know that joe biden
doesn't have the political talent to get
himself out of this method he's not
clean
obama he's not trump geraldo you
remember how down donald trump was
during his presidency you see him down
in february in terms of his personality
polling look at
february 2020 he'd beat an impeachment
50 percent approval rating in gallup
wiped it isis
the progressives
have now taken over in a coup the
democratic party isn't biden's real
problem
aside from you know this the tactical
stuff that aoc and they've become the
moral center of the party there was no
coup the left is the democrat party that
we're only talking about a handful of
so-called moderates who still want
trillions in spain but i forgot who he
was don't you think that he lied about
who i know he was never a moderate he
was there as a trojan horse and now the
horses come up lame her although you
know this is true because if you look at
the headlines it says moderates in the
senate holding up biden's agenda which
proves that joe biden is actually the
radical yeah he's with bernie on this
girl though well you got tristan cinema
and joe manchin that's the moderates and
the that's not joe biden people but not
joe biden
i'm steve ducey i'm brian kilmeade and
i'm ainslie earhart and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis